alors évidemment [ __ ] dure c'est
beaucoup plus violent que [ __ ] douce
c'est l'intrusion de bertrand blier qui
fait ça c'est beaucoup moins sympa c'est
beaucoup moins gay friendly c'est
violent qu'on veut dire c'est quand tu
dit gay friendly c'est à dire se serait
montré les homosexuels comme ils ont
envie d'être vu c'est ça oui voilà dany
boon vous êtes né le 26 juin 66
armentières non mais c'est un peu c'est
un peu quand même là
c'est le parallèle à ces jeux sans
détour d'un peu de
sérieux
c'est rien c'est pour une télé régionale
des titres rock au fil des caméras c'est
merci concerne le cinéma maintenant tu
joue dans la cour des grands
thierry pardon je voulais pas de couper
en plus contre ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya quand même une suite en
collision qui est tout à fait il ya une
collision entre la folie douce deux
avions et la folie dur de manon et
prochain one man show
ça me fait plaisir que vous me posiez
cette question
laurent parce que justement ça va se
faire la main tenant pas s en écriture
on peut le dire et pas de caméra sur
nous pas la peine pour l'instant
non c'est vrai bien sûr que c'est vrai
que je me souviens plus de ce que vous
me dire
c'est que les tellement bien qu'elle se
fait sur quand tu as des gens c'est vrai
qu'il soit maintenu la question quand la
question c'est qu'il ya une collision
entre la folie douce d'avion et la folie
dur d'oublier en 1989 vous monter à
paris
et là c'est les premiers boulots la
période à la colère très difficile très
dur de galère où je faisais pas de télé
régionale et
non c'est vrai
mais les sujets qui font partie a bien
un truc dans ce film c'est qu'une
collision
l'émission est diffusée dans l'émission
direct
nous on est sur le régional avec celle
de national
non mais c'est vrai que les sujets
abordés sont récemment oui
la région des amis à ce sujet les sujets
abordés sont des sujets finale du lourd
le dvd du chantier
bagdad pour armentières déçu je m'étais
mise en place d'un tiers leur parentèle
c'est encore les rapports au mot et
l'hérault les rapports hommes/femmes
enfin des des sujets de société quoi
c'est vrai
ses oreilles dany ses oreilles c'est
incroyable carrière ou de malefoy
maintenant on avait dit pas uniquement
des questions
[Musique]
gérard et dany c'est la première fois
que vous jouez des homosexuels oui comme
ça oui
moi je fais une fois avec danger la robe
bonsoir
merci de passer dans notre belle région
non il est sous la il est sympa et je le
connais mais c'est la première fois que
gérard et dany j'ai l'impression michel
réaliser un peu dans les films homo mais
c'est la première fois qu'on ait quoi
que ce soit remonté
c'est la première fois que vous jouez
donc tous les deux des rôles
d'homosexuels wing ou non non moi dans
un film de jugnot j'avais déjà fait ça
une fois mais c'était plutôt une
caricature et c'était sans compter sans
reproche une caricature il a là c'est
vraiment vous quoi là c'est vraiment moi
oui et puis il ya eu cet accident de
voiture personnelle réagit donc tout le
monde de se présenter
alors ça vous plairait dans la vie je
vais essayer d'en tirer les séquelles
encore aujourd'hui j'ai tu réponds ce
que discret pour dutronc c'est à dire
que je pense que je ne serai jamais
parce que imagine que j'aime et que
j'adore ça le temps que j'aurais perdu
ouais ça c'est vrai donc je vais pas
essayer mais depuis que vous avez fait
le film avec dany vous vous prenez des
douches avec les potes après le sport on
vous a un petit peu modifiée non s'est
il m'arrive de laver des deux genres
vous pensez la moustache dany maintenant
non ça ça se voit c'est simplement ça
pousse pas
j'aime bien ce côté imberbe - trouve sa
vie dans rabbi jacob
scène avec les roms
c'est l'inoubliable crois qu'on va voir
l'extrait de
millas un moment quand même vous vous
êtes dit tous les deux si c'était vrai
qu'on vit ensemble oui non non je pense
je pense pas plus deux enfin je vois que
ça ça fait un peu de peine à nice que je
vais atteindre que oui il ya un moment
où j'ai vu il avait réellement envisager
ce que j'aime encore un peu toyer comme
séquelle michel ta fleur préférée la vie
voir
et vous d'amis
je suis pas aigri
et vous des amis non c'est pire après
vous seriez open pour des plans à trois
mais comment je peux écrire des
conneries comme ça me sourit aux peines
pour des plans à trois scellés tacleur
préféré donner parce que je suis sur
l'autre chaîne
de promo en même temps ça c'est de
gérard c'est l'album s'est très bien
vendu que je n'ai pas tu n'étais pas un
chanteur d'occasions on a un vrai
chanteur c'était par un deuxième album
absolument ouest nice et voila voila ca
enregistre là et j'en suis là après
après le film que cela je vais tourner
je vais faire mon deuxième album et la
tournée bientôt et avant-hier peut-être
à le faire sur mon cher non sur bon chez
vous adressez vous à armentières où léa
thiry je te rend l'antenne merci laurent
michel dans la vraie vie vous partiriez
avec lequel des deux sur une île déserte
oh la la hc levier ou le léguer bon
pas facile hein
c'était vrai ce qu'ils savent pas réussi
sur la télé régionale
je ne suis pas sûr je peux pas avec
lequel vous pourriez dormir dans le même
lit sans de ce gaz quoi que ce soit
pourquoi il doit pas se passer quelque
chose
sont marqués par le film c'est lui qui
regardent le plus marqué un
but ce qu'il a pris
vraiment que dominique segall va être
content de la promotion vous venez de
faire la queue je crois qu'il va être
extrêmement content armentières c'est
très bon - paris je sais parce que le
film parle de lui-même oui donc on nous
aide vraiment parler que je voulais
qu'on met sur ce film dont vous avez
très bien résumé la situation
les trois français que c'est un couple
pacsé
qui acquit qui désirent un enfant qu'une
mère poc et une mère je pense que voilà
le racé ces deux là c'est de la comédie
moi je trouve que la réunion des deux de
l'univers de blier qui était très très
acide qui a un regard comme ça
oui sur l'homosexualité
c'est assez pathétique et alors il est
il ya aussi le pathétisme daguillon qui
lui le le transmet avec le rire il aime
bien la comédie il aime bien un peu
comme ces travaux un peu comme ces
travestis qui sont tout à fait maquiller
quantis démaquillant de souche n'a pas
eu à faire un plus reibel ils me
chambrent merci armentières
voilà après leur est bon c'est celle et
celle en vie ou non du du public je
pense que saddam
ce n'est pas du tout la suite je crois
de [ __ ] douce c'est le deuxième volet
de [ __ ] douce ses neuf ans après le
monde homosexuel à bouger à changer la
société a changé c'est autre chose alors
c'est peut-être un peu plus grinçant que
le premier effectivement ils en parlent
bien
dont metz quand on s est parlé quand
armentières tout ça sera coupée au
montage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux